[موسيقى]
منذ اللحظة التي تم فيها إطلاق 747
في عام 1968
عشق الطيارون بالطائرة الجامبو
كانت طائرة كادت أن تفلس
بوينج
وبان آم كلا الشركتين راهنت كثيرًا على
أنها ستكون ناجحة ويا له من
نجاح
في رحلتها الأولى  من نيويورك إلى لندن
إيذانا بعصر ذهبي جديد من السفر
عندما كان الركاب لا يزالون يرتدون ملابس الطيران
وكان 747 قمة
الدرج الحلزوني المؤدي إلى
الطابق العلوي الشهير مع صالات الدرجة الأولى ،
فأنت لم تكن شركة طيران عالمية إذا لم تفعل ذلك
لم يكن لديك 747
في أسطولك ، ولذا فقد حاولت بوينج منذ أكثر
من أربعة
عقود بث
حياة جديدة في الطائرة مع 747-8
العابرة للقارات ، لكن عددًا قليلاً فقط من شركات الطيران
اشترتها ، وكانت أيام الطائرة مرقمة على أنها
توأم أكثر كفاءة في استهلاك الوقود
استلمت طائرات A350s triple sevens شركة Boeing
وأعلنت نهاية الإنتاج
وشركات الطيران مثل
سنغافورة وتوحدت مع حفل كبير
لإزالة الجامبو من
أسطولها الآن وقد شاهدت الحكومة طائرات الركاب من
أجل حسن
إدارة الأعمال.  سيتم إرسال
الجامبو المتوقف لإلغاء أول رحلة لي 747 كانت رحلة People Express في عام 1983 من جاتويك إلى نيوارك ،
وأعلم الآن أن آخر رحلة لي كانت في ديسمبر
2019. الخطوط الجوية البريطانية من مطار هيثرو
إلى جون كينيدي لقد أحببت دائمًا طائرة
747 وما زلت ألتقط صورًا لها
عندما أراهم في المطارات ، كانت
علاقة حب استمرت ثلاثة عقود
مع ملكة السماء
[موسيقى] ،
لذا فإن رحلتي الأولى منذ ما يقرب من أربعة أشهر
وهي أطول فترة انفصال عن
الطيران
عرفت أنني لا أعرفها  نعرف 35
40 عامًا
أن المطار هادئ ولكن ليس
هادئًا بشكل مفرط ، فهناك بالتأكيد
نوع متزايد من
التخوف من توتر التوقعات
مهما كان ما تريد
تسميته بالضبط ما يمكن توقعه في كل
قطعة مختلفة من اللغز ، يبدو
المطار متناثرًا جدًا
، ويبدو أن جميع المطاعم متناثرة  أن تكون مغلقًا
أو على الأقل ليس من الواضح على الفور
أين
يمكنك الحصول على شيء ما للأكل ،
كل شيء
جاهز وربما يكون كذلك ،
لكنه لم يكن موجودًا بعد ، لقد قمت بهذه
الرحلة
مرات عديدة ومع ذلك فهي كذلك
أشعر بالاختلاف مع معرفة الظروف التي
تعرف فيها الحالة
العاجزة لصناعة الطيران ،
وإدراك عدد المضيفات
والطاقم الذين على وشك أن يفقدوا
وظائفهم ،
وهو أمر كان طبيعيًا جدًا بالنسبة
لي ، وهو الآن مختلف تمامًا
إذا نظرت إلى رحلة  نظرًا لأن
الطائرة أقلعت من المحركات ، استمر
الطيار في التحرك وكان الطيار يعرف
الطريق وكان يشبه إلى حد كبير أي رحلة أخرى ،
لكن كان بعيدًا عن ذلك لأنني كنت
عاطفيًا
جدًا لشخص يسافر مثلي كثيرًا ،
فقد كانت تجربة رائعة حقًا
أول
رحلة بعد أربعة أشهر
وكل شيء مختلف تمامًا ،
النحت الواسع المنحدر في محطة الملكة ،
لذلك وصلت إلى مطار هيثرو وبداية
ما أنا متأكد من أنه سيكون
العديد من الرحلات الجوية في الأسابيع والأشهر
المقبلة ، كل شيء مختلف تمامًا يمكنك.
لنقول بالضبط
إنها تجربة ممتعة بشكل خاص
ولكننا سنعتاد عليها
وسنبدأ في السفر مرة
أخرى وسرعان ما ستتساءل جيدًا أن هذا هو
بالضبط ما هو عليه
يشعر الناس بقليل من الازدحام في الوقت الحالي ، يعتقد الدكتور ديفيد دامسكور أن مقاطعته كانت خارج الغابة ، وهو يقود الصحة العامة لمقاطعة باكز في بنسلفانيا خارج فيلادلفيا في فترة الأربعة أيام الأخيرة ، حيث سجل مئات حالات الإصابة بفيروس كورونا الجديد. يقول دامسكور العديد من هؤلاء إذا كان الأشخاص الذين سافروا إلى شاطئ ميرتل في جنوب كارولينا يعتبرون الآن بقعة ساخنة ، فقد رأينا حوالي نصف حالاتنا الجديدة من الأشخاص المصابين أثناء سفرهم ، فهذه قصة مدعومة بالنتائج الجديدة من جامعة ميريلاند. يستخدم دارزي وفريق من الباحثين بيانات الهاتف الذكي لمعرفة أين يذهب الناس خلال عطلة الرابع من يوليو (تموز) ، حيث وصل معدل سفر الأشخاص إلى مستوى جائحة جديد في جميع أنحاء البلاد ، توقعنا أن نشهد المزيد من الرحلات خلال الإجازات ، ولكننا نعود إلى ما كنا عليه من قبل لقد كان الوباء مفاجئًا بعض الشيء بالنسبة لنا ، لذلك يشعر الناس بالأمان بشكل أساسي للقيام برحلة برية تمامًا ، حيث يمكن للاتجاه المقلق أن ينشر حالات جديدة من n
يقول التعرض لجامعة
لويزا
فرانزيني إنني أشعر بالقلق لأنه بالتأكيد عندما
يسافر الناس يجلبون الفيروس
معهم ،
فإنها تحث الولايات على النظر في المزيد من
إرشادات السفر ،
وسعت نيو جيرسي قائمتها
لتخبر المسافرين من المزيد من الولايات
بالحجر الصحي
لمدة 14 يومًا في بعض الولايات.
سيحتاج إلى أن يكون جديدًا
لأن الفيروس خارج عن السيطرة
توقعت AAA أن تنخفض الرحلات البرية
بنسبة 3 في المائة فقط
هذا الصيف ، لكن مكتب
إحصاءات النقل وجد أن رحلات 4 يوليو التي
تزيد عن 50 ميلاً زادت
مقارنة بالعام الماضي
حاكم ميريلاند لاري هوجان يؤكد
الآن  وقت اليقظة ،
وليس الإجازات ، لهذا الفيروس نوعًا
ما عقل خاص به ، وهو
لا يتعرف على
الحدود ، لذلك يسافر الناس من ولاية
إلى أخرى ،
فنحن نشاهده كثيرًا
[موسيقى]
لدي أربعة  أربعة أطفال ، أصغرهم
يبلغ من العمر عشرة أشهر ،
تعلمون أن أكبر همومهم هو
السفر مع الأطفال ، ولا أريدهم
أن يمرضوا ويبلغ عمرهم حوالي 10 شهور  عندما تبلغ من
العمر ستصبح سترغب في
الزحف بشكل صحيح إنها في تلك السن حيث
ستضع كل شيء في فمها بشكل
صحيح وهي دائمًا ما تلمس الأشياء
ثم القلق الآخر هو أنك
تعرف الآن
أنه من الصعب أن أثق بالآخرين.  فكر
جيدًا أولاً وقبل كل شيء
في فئتي العمرية ، أعني أنني في الفئة بأكملها
أم أنك تعلم أنني أبلغ من العمر 70 عامًا ، لذا فأنت تعلم أنني في
هذه
الفئة لديك حشود في
المطارات تمر بالأمن ،
لذا فأنت تعرض فقط  أنت نفسك
وأكثر من ذلك
لديك أشخاص مصابين بهذا الفيروس قد
لا تظهر عليهم
الأعراض حتى تعرف أنك على
متن الطائرة
وبعد ذلك يكون الوقت قد فات إذا كنت على
وجه الخصوص إذا كنت مسافرًا إلى الخارج ،
فلا يمكنك الذهاب إلى أي مكان تتواجد فيه  عالق في
الوقت الحاضر نحن نتفهم أن شركات
الطيران تبيع المقعد الأوسط ، لذلك من
الصعب الحفاظ على التباعد
الاجتماعي وقد تكون في الواقع مسافرًا إلى منطقة
عالية
العدوى ، وهي منطقة ينتشر فيها الفيروس ،
على سبيل المثال ، لديّ أنا وزوجتي
مكان صغير جدًا في فلوريدا و  نحن عادة
نحب  هاء للذهاب إلى هناك في الصيف
ولكن فلوريدا أصبحت
عدوى شديدة لدرجة أننا لن نذهب إلى
هناك هذا
الصيف لندمنا المتبادل ، وأخشى
أن يكون لديك
خريطة وجه أو غطاء
على
الإطلاق سأنتظر "  سأنتظر ما دمت مضطرًا
حتى عندما يتوفر لقاح ،
فلن أكون أول من
ينفد وأحصل عليه ، أود التأكد من
أنه سيكون فعالًا ويعمل ،
أعني
إذا استمر  عام ، ربما سنتان ،
هذا ما يتعين علينا القيام به ،
أعني أنك تعلم أنني بالتأكيد أريد
أن يخرج الأطفال ، أريد أن تذهب زوجتي
للقيام بالأشياء التي يريدون القيام بها ، أريد أن
أفعل الأشياء التي أريد القيام بها ولكن في  هذه
المرة ، هذا ما
أعنيه تمامًا ، لذا يتعين علينا نوعًا ما أن نتحمله
ونحقق أقصى استفادة من وقتنا